se le suman los problemas a justin todo
y en medio de la presión de las críticas
por su gestión de los bloqueos
considerada demasiado permisiva este
martes renunció peter slowly con mucho
dolor anunció mi renuncia al cargo de
jefe policía de ottawa horas antes en el
parlamento el primer ministro de canadá
tuvo que defender ante una alborotada
oposición la declaración de la ley de
emergencias para combatir las protestas
que asola en el país desde hace dos
semanas
siempre defenderemos los derechos de los
canadienses a la reunión pacífica ya la
libertad de expresión pero estos
bloqueos deben terminar y
lamentablemente los políticos
conservadores continúan alentando a los
líderes de estos bloqueos su aplicación
otorga amplios poderes a las autoridades
permitirá cortar la financiación de
manifestantes y prohibir bloqueos en
cruces fronterizos aeropuertos y en la
capital ottawa
es el segundo en aplicar las medidas de
emergencia en tiempos de paz el primero
fue su padre pierre trudeau en respuesta
a los independentistas quebequenses la
diferencia de su padre el primer
ministro liberal asegura que no va a
utilizar a los militares sin embargo la
medida no ha contentado a los
conservadores
no es cierto que las acciones del primer
ministro podrían empeorar las cosas en
lugar de mejorar las 6
los manifestantes continúan sus bloqueos
e incluso sacan techo
la bandera canadiense es el símbolo de
la libertad en todo el mundo es
asombroso y creo que lo que está
sucediendo es efecto bola de nieve
continuará
el movimiento liderado por camioneros
desde finales de enero tiene el apoyo de
anti vacunas y la extrema derecha
estadounidense su objetivo acabar con
los mandatos de vacunación y otras
restricciones aunque por el momento por
lo que han acabado con la histórica fama
de estabilidad de canadá